نعم معزه اجواء هستيريه هنا في محيطه
استاذ المدينه التعليميه هذا الملعب الذي
كان شاهدا على هذه الملحمه التاريخيه
الكرويه للمنتخب المغربي الذي ضمن ظهورا
للعرب لاول مره في تاريخ مشاركتهم في كاس
العالم الت
الوبر لا صوتها يعلو فوق صوت الاسود فوز
انتظره العرب كثيرا يعني بكل المقاييس
المنتخب المغربي اليوم كانوا ابطال على
الملعب جاره منتخب قويا المنتخب الاسباني
همم حتى وصلنا الى ركلات الترجيح التي كان
فيها ياسين بونو بطلا وعريسا لهذه الليله
اذا الافراح في كل مكان هنا الجماهير
سعيده جدا بهذا الاجازه تاريخي ساضرك لهم
الكلمه الاجواء والميكروفون السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته والصراحه الفوز
مستحق كبير من المنتخب الوطني المغربي على
نظير اسباني وهذا جاء من اجل اللاعبين
كانوا في مستوى رائع ومتجلد الدول العربيه
كلها وصراحه تنظيم خيالي لدوله عربيه
اسمها قطر نظمت تنظيم خيالي والمنتخب
الوطني المغربي ممثل كل الدول العربيه
الحقني المنتخب المغربي هيقول الكلمه
دياله في المباراه المقبله ان شاء الله
اليوم المنتخب المغربي كانه رجال معانا
120 دقيقه وارفعوا راسنا لفوق وان شاء
الله انساهلون لافينال وعلاش لا ما نديرش
الكاس
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك حمزه